today on our show oh we're going deep on
some trailers son right there are a lot
of trailers that we're gonna hitch our
[ __ ] trailer to and we're going to
talk about some movies that he saw one
of them has some magic in it that's
right he just teased a [ __ ] magic
movie man now you see me three Legend of
Curly's go all had so much more on
today's brand new fat man on Batman
ma'am in the Minuteman min a minute man
welcome back to fat man on Batman I'm
Kevin Smith I'm mark barnardine uh we
like [ __ ] folks we like movies we like
comics TV show we like TV shows we like
music we like anything any real
essentially hmm you came here to talk
sports
keep moving not your bag baby uh but if
you came here to talk movie trailers
then tonight's or today's whenever
you're watching this episode is your
[ __ ] poison man because we're gonna
talk some [ __ ] trailers we're gonna
show them no watch those online I think
it's kind of silly Billy let's [ __ ]
run the truck look at the trailer
everybody knows what it is yeah I'm sure
ugh right next to in a window on the
YouTube that's just trailer trailer
trailer close I don't want to be off the
internet I want to stay with the
Internet so am I gonna replace us with a
trailers [ __ ] let's talk first and
foremost Wonder Woman trailer yes
outstanding cannot wait I was in the bag
for this movie I'm even more so every
spot looking better and better I mean it
was always looking [ __ ] good like the
idea of a Wonder Woman movie just
[ __ ] good business is smart
I was worried like World War One what
the [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ] anymore
no I'm so on board the shot of those
[ __ ] soldiers on Paradise Island
that's something we didn't know Steve
Trevor
[ __ ] lands on Paradise Island is the
old story and I was rescued by Diana and
then you know she goes back to man's
world but in this version of the story
he's [ __ ] followed by a bunch of dudes
and they [ __ ] war on paradise on the
no man's land take my [ __ ] money
they're shootin [ __ ] in the face with
arrows and [ __ ] and it's ears as if
Diana gets exiled so what it is it feels
like well it seems like she's steered in
the based on the second yeah she takes
the shield she takes a sword
yeah like because she invited Steve
Trevor on and he brought people with
like she transgressed against the rules
on Paradise Island this writer I think I
miss Kira bounces him out of [ __ ]
town
[ __ ] hey man and so she'd bring this
bringing this fellow along he'll explain
any trailer to you that's my job guys I
didn't [ __ ] him really good point man
that trailer looks for all our fighting
scenes look fantastic they've shown a
little bit more we mostly it's the same
footage we
from the comic-con trailer but this was
the first official trailer yes that was
a commercial trailer quite count yeah
it's like I only saw that online yeah
that's a big-ass teaser this feels like
this is real deals where the movies
about I can't wait and it opens with her
being the Diana from Batman V Superman
mm-hmm looking back on her past and
stuff yes hopefully getting hard drives
from lex luthor and explaining [ __ ] yeah
cuz what is my symbol o Thank You Lex
Luthor I appreciate you graphically
designing my club I guess I'll just
stick with this who are these other
symbols how much did you pay to have
this logo created man that's $100,000
like Nike level design work I mean very
sweet just saying looks like a 70 year
old logo thanks Lex um that movie looks
[ __ ] dope when is it coming out um
March what no I'm just excited this is
all I want to see it yeah who's director
patty Jagger patty Jenkins patty Jenkins
yeah who walked away somebody else uh
woman director yeah but now patty
Jenkins is the dress yeah she directed
monster and now she directed this I
can't remember who the other director
was who walked away
um president Lotus's Hardwick then I'm
Catherine Hardwicke now she didn't she
wasn't see what they got she was on
Twilight and then they did not bring her
back for Twilight where I fix that the
one I'm thinking of mm-hmm she did that
Little Red Riding Hood movie after that
I think ya know we're falling
mammographic a real I know is that as
America's Wonder Woman [ __ ] patty
Jenkins is directing a [ __ ] out of
Wonder Woman that looks awesome I want
to feel good one see it right now Wonder
Woman that
best part obviously committee bridge on
us your cello are you saying jaar jaar
jaar jaar jaar are you getting a second
pop culture it out of it I'm gonna name
you my god that's genius
uh-uh yes Wonder Woman looks [ __ ] I
give it four golden lariats up yes oh
that's over my normal two golden lariat
max one for bad to forget a terrible
scale I need more larious it's like
pass/fail really that's Bill Larry you
got one shot with this guy 5050 what
else have we seen trailers valerian [ __ ]
Valeri in the mouth and this movie looks
phenomenal
he's a vision there Luke missile the
great look of a song who I spoke to four
at San Diego man in GB boat lovely
[ __ ] dude and I've loved his [ __ ] man
I love every one of his movies really
you guys everyone I love every one of
his move everyone that requires us who
you ain't hardened God did I want so
Oldman you could you went deep because
you didn't have the pill you didn't have
the pill that makes that happen that's
true there's more so that's true I did
it's palpable in he was Austrian you
know um but I find bait a little light
for this kind of work
wow that hurt but it was worth it it
really was there's nice child care about
burn my vocal cords and I blow out of
Mike and I'm sure your [ __ ] ears
everywhere just [ __ ] talking about
furloughs Luke the son [ __ ] look
Bassam I'm alone every one of his movies
everyone yeah man so this will be
valerian he loved this comic book
valerian and the city and a thousand
planets is that a city of a thousand
planets what a great title since he was
a kid he's been dreaming about making
this movie since he was [ __ ] 12 or 13
got close he made his own version of a
I fi fantasy fifth element which is a
wonderful movie Bruce Willis
notwithstanding he's really [ __ ]
wonderful flick and he's great in it too
um and that was him getting close look
pasand that was his valerian right
but then he saw avatar right he had a
script it was like ready to go
so avatar said oh [ __ ] this is too close
tore it up and said I'm a [ __ ] star
from scratch and we got a visionary
movie on all of these words are bad all
of them everyone the trailer has that
amazing Beatles song because yeah which
must have costs $150 I think he bought
it on iTunes $2.99 he got the [ __ ]
remix version uh yeah I use this song
easy song a very expensive one I don't
know but gives me Beatles I went because
uh why because he deserves it the
[ __ ] troll looks phenomenal that's
some filmmaking right there that dudes
visually [ __ ] he's visually amazing
and a [ __ ] businessman yeah like he's
the runs you over for a while he was
like he would for a while he was like
I'm not direct anymore the tires
producing yeah and he produced like the
transporter movies in the transporter
movies he taken oh my god you're right
[ __ ] the transporter like he's got all
that fat taken month to sweet taking
money like that was his that was his jam
for a long time like yeah like he had
Cola suddenly the solution I'm a [ __ ]
filmmaker and he was a filmmaker that
money's producing him and writing him
but now he's in the director chair again
yeah but you know and his movies like I
he is one of the few foreign directors
especially from Europe who really like
imprinted on America yeah you know like
there had never been a French director
who came over and made movies like
professional and like La Femme Nikita
the Femme Nikita remember took like I
loved la Femme Nikita and it was hailed
as a like an art film he came from
France yeah but [ __ ] it's as American as
it gets but there were some people that
will I remember like the [ __ ] shitty
people that were like this is the death
of French cinema because he is making an
American movie now because they said it
was so glossy but I say bullsh
[ __ ] he [ __ ] created a look that got
bit by a lot of [ __ ] American
directors he didn't he wasn't following
his stuff name in glossy but it didn't
look like anything else no they're like
three international directors who really
like to me in my limited film
scholarship have had a vast impact on
American film has the [ __ ] editor Thea
Lee top section my limited films worst
movies right and I don't mean earnest
like thoughtful I mean earnest P war L
hey burn like it especially when you'd
like post the like Billy Wilder's and
and von Stroheim sand all those guys
right akira kurosawa who I've heard that
name bad name
luc besson oh I know that name John Woo
yeah I feel cultured I knew all those
names but like those gauges let's me
tagging it twisted and shaped and reform
the way we thought about cinema from the
outside and also from the outside using
forms that blown to America get miss
angle he's on a roll quick like Seven
Samurai
like was supposed to be a Western like
because Akira Kurosawa loved John Ford
Western so like I want to make a Western
it's gonna have summarized in it what
happens it gets remade a thousand times
over and over and over again so that the
best westerns lean on the Cure core so
magnificent some I mean the nineties
action movies all ended up looking like
La Femme Nikita they all have that slick
look they all like between that and
Michael Mann and Miami Vice was like the
juncture point for what 90s action
cinema looked like nice then John Woo
shows up and everybody is carrying two
[ __ ] guns yeah like that's theory
this way yeah and jumping and firing
yeah that's the only reason anybody in
any movies after 1956 held two guns was
because John was a job maybe there's
that crazy action because the crazy
hyper kinetise isn't over the slow
motion of it the dugs ever new guns
birds are
I love you man I love you too you know
like those were the three guys for me
who kind of especially from overseas
looked at the way Americans him at work
synthesized it gave us their version of
war Luke at it leaked at it took a would
look at it but yeah so an absolutely
Bassam is one of those guys this movie
looks fantastic and I mean fantastic in
the original form of the word fantastic
as in a fantasy mm-hmm like it comes
from fancy boy it looks [ __ ] like it
looks like the comic material man yes
like that [ __ ] book I can't pronounce
the creator of that books name it's
great super French very super all of the
French but man oh man this movie looks
fantastic that's Dean Dane Dane DeHaan
and what's her name Cara Delevingne
who was the in a chance to assess looks
like they give her more to do in this
yes and Dane DeHaan was the he was a dad
government Osborn not Harry Osborn I was
born in spider-man Allison Chronicle
which he's much better in did you hear
that [ __ ] I heard this on Hollywood
babble-on a podcast you should all be
listening to read it uh that they're
gonna remake American Werewolf in London
with max landis I think that is adorable
I think that's such a great idea there
should be a rule that only a filmmakers
kids get to remake his move that way my
kid all have a job one day
um I think that's awesome number one is
great writer hmm number two uh like I
love that movie and if they were like
someone's remaking it would have made me
upset but his kid remaking it makes me
happy for some reason I mean there's at
least the idea I love though that's a
sacred text yeah that he will feel the
responsibility to it because he's grown
up with it good storytelling man kids
like [ __ ] bright that's the other
thing it's not like he might actually
improve the pond she could or the very
least you know we will feel responsible
enough to not [ __ ] it up he was not even
alive when they made that movie nope I
was some axe blow me up yeah how'd you
boy call us and we'll tell you
you're doing the right thing oh my god I
look for I'm telling you that would have
made me so mad if they were like we're
remaking America Movil for London and it
was almost anybody else maybe Quentin
Tarantino I'd be like oh I'd watch that
right but it would make me Maxim I come
on even Quentin knows better you don't
need to remake that movie it's [ __ ]
perfection man that movie's brilliant
still [ __ ] holds up but that being
said they threw to one [ __ ] card down
where I'm like alright I'll watch that
his kid John Landis his kid max landis
directing his dad's old mature come on
all of that is [ __ ] win so I'm I'm all
for this alright excellent beating the
beast trailer dropped saw it yeah
looks exactly like the cartoon which is
a good thing but thicker
yeah 3d no more 3d in [ __ ] like that
yeah he looks cool the Beast looks cool
looks great he does but there is this
weird light I think it I mean look I
take anything away from Emma Thompson
she's amazing
why not just [ __ ] get Angela Lansbury
but she's still [ __ ] so they're kicking
she just said you watch that internet
clip like two months back yeah she's
sang Beauty and the Beast live in front
of like people I don't know where was
some more cultured and she was amazing
like they brought her out she's you know
jump there and eight years old I think
she may be in her nineties you wouldn't
even know how to tell you she might as
well been seventy misuses belting it out
sounded the exact same and she just now
retired from the stage that's a like two
or three weeks ago was like you know
what that's I mean look can't do it
shows a week anymore
everybody 92 years old everybody's
allowed to retire but that's a [ __ ]
loss for for the theater but you imagine
being like a that good and be in that
advanced stage and only just now
realizing you don't have the stamina to
do eight days a week
yeah I might just slow down yeah like
the stage a bit too much for me it's too
much for me and I'm 44 years old that
being said I love that Matassa too so
it's cool that she's mrs. Potts but it's
just a little bad all this looks [ __ ]
awesome it's gonna make all the magneto
is a candelabra right mmm is he that
Lumiere I think no where's Gregor your
McGregor is Damir oh really yeah and so
Indian McKellen is the clock hog tour
yeah
believe that I'm certain like oh I
remember all these character the foo
isn't it little kid little guy hums out
with uh-huh
Gaston Gaston they got everything go
play look look evidence plays guest on
uh Kevin Kline plays your dad does he
yeah I saw him in the trailer I have not
seen Kevin Kline on screen and Hermione
plays a [ __ ] yeah and lots of the
beasts
oh no different movie different movie I
I saw that cartoon differently but
others yeah there's there's a version of
that though somewhere in the internet
Shrek kinda totally at the end she comes
like beastly-looking well she was
beastly she wasn't meant to be right
person or I forget it but I like that
lesson in track like at the end she
turned into the lady Shrek I was like
[ __ ] Idol let's be a people roll man
turn to the normies neck feels like a
doctor took off [ __ ] you what you saw
the other top is at its flying fat
people roll it world um think they'll be
another Shrek I'll be right I mean at
some point yeah I mean that's one of the
reasons why Garvin money yeah why I'm
wide Universal bought DreamWorks look so
they can keep print that's right they
can just scale it up like we want to
make more than two animated movies a
year we can do for we want a Shrek
universe man gingerbread man gets his
own [ __ ] move they already did like
[ __ ] expand the strike universe put
some blue yeah TV show that's right on
the middle ayah [ __ ] our board Brian
Lynch yes a good life of pets
I do minions and pounds on fire i sat
next to him at the such a good at the
Civil War premiere and didn't know I was
sitting next to him at the Civil War
premiere until after the Civil War
premiere and we're seeing a Twitter like
where it like he's like I sat next to
the [ __ ] Nathan Fillion I'm like I
said makes anything feeling were you
sitting next to me I was any next to you
it's like the best meet-cute story to
marvel it me really is he's good dude
man
he's him he's like he's like real
[ __ ] strong writer but he's prolific
is [ __ ] everybody buddy writes as
fast as much as he does and it's all
good it's not like hey this is fast and
a lot but it's crap like he's always got
great ideas you two together and make
something me
one of these days we have to meet and
know we're in the same place good dude
axe good dad - I fought him on Instagram
yeah yeah he's big like he loves his kid
like everybody loves her kids but like
he doing it right it's good for him um
okay what else we got I've seen some
movies are we done with the trail we're
done with the trailers nothing else has
happened no one's comin soon all right
what did you see I've seen fantastic
beasts and where to find them the Harry
Potter
yes in the Bombers that is the first pot
of verse movie outside the books yeah
there's a no mention of Harry Potter or
the Leo James Potter really yeah nobody
no no Baltimore nothing like that
there's a I don't think there's a
mention of Voldemort they mentioned
Albus Dumbledore a little bit in there
that's gonna be the moment where I'm
like wow by the lighter in my pocket I'd
[ __ ] be like Dumbledore more
references to Dumbledore I'm not as
invested but I want more Dumbledore how
was it I was not that big a fan oh
really yeah like Dumbledore Mordor bald
man here's the thing I am a ride-or-die
for Harry Potter like I was one of that
first wave of adults who were reading it
on the train going into work right i
watch all the movies I've seen them all
more than once I've read every book
cover-to-cover I did not read the
fantastic beasts like booklets that JK
wrote in between but for me the magic of
Harry Potter the magic with that world
is the boy who lived better be on a
single illness you know like the the
reason why that story is so affecting is
because you spend so much time with
Harry yeah you understand why he's in
such a bad place you feel for that kid
like his parents are gone and even worse
his parents are gone because of him like
his parents sacrificed themselves for
him so that he could live and Voldemort
the big bad guy of that cycle yeah
intrinsically tied to Harry Potter yes
like the two of them cannot exist
without each other and they're woven
together and it's beautiful and so when
Harry gets to go to Hogwarts like you
felt for him so long like he gets a
family who loves and buys this [ __ ]
out from under the stairs series gonna
get a room they gave him an owl the kids
been abused
literally for anyway you would
and abuse has been abused for eight or
nine years gets to go to place where
he's respected and loved and he I don't
have to share a bathroom this [ __ ]
fat cousin not at all he gets to go to
school like a real live boy and that's
the story of Harry Potter II went from a
puppet line boy who can lie all he wants
but the thing that that fantastic beasts
doesn't have is that character that we
care that much about it's about newts
there's no Harry Potter
there's no Harry Potter's needs
commander this guy who's a magic wall
just to the world Jupiter rising that is
anyway I'm going to kill your planet
does he do that in this movie not so
much but there's a lot of leg left that
one of the trick bag listen I've got my
Oscar that's been on shows anymore but
so eases magic zoologist guy who goes
all over the world and collects a little
magical crash accent he's got a British
accent
cuz it's Harry Potter one goes to
America goes to New York nineteen twenty
something Jazz Age New York finally
they're talking about our world our
world Romano is British people and [ __ ]
American muggles American muggle wait
for me
Anna Nana Megan muggle fantastic beasts
and where to find them everything well a
friend yes I can do this yeah you don't
need to overpay from Harkin called me
I'm a jingle man like y'all right now to
put that [ __ ] on loop you have to secure
the rights to America on first but yeah
I mean this whatever that guys probably
did do they have any songs in or just
score
no they're just score um I don't know
it's very evocative I mean it's got a
little bit John well it's not John
Williams but it borrows some of the John
Williams he themes to it because you
can't do a Harry Potter esque world
movie without it but I mean for me I
just found it like not entirely
I didn't feel for that character he lost
some creatures he wants to get them back
fine the world is not hanging the
balance because if he does what he does
or doesn't do sound like whose big
adventure it's a bit like that but even
like you feel more for Pb than you felt
for that guy
boy yeah I won't even give it the peewee
I won't even give it a baby who is the
best in it
actually con Farrell is kind of really
good he plays always good let's do it
find the rub in bruges is amazing but
they never find the right [ __ ] way to
harness that dudes power yeah I mean it
I see guys brilliant actor the problem
is is that he's not meant to be a movie
star
he likes that what I think you don't I
think he's just like a really good actor
who does small movies like supporting
roles like he's not no not a movie
Serbian movies right might be in movies
but like you're not going to be that guy
you're not going to be the mark you're
not gonna be Clooney like not everybody
can be Clooney but if you're the dude
extra cleaning it makes cleaning look
better that is equally bad Damon yeah
and then you become that Damon yeah I
mean I was talking a little bit today in
the office of that Brad Pitt who is by
any light a movie star yeah but every
Brad Pitt movie and performance you
remember he was a supporting role yeah
usually the George Clooney yeah like or
like he's great if he broke out of film
in Louie's he's great in twelve Monkeys
he's amazing in true romance
he's like condescend me bring Maxim
foods and cleaning products to alright
so he's so Colin Brad it's not in this
book please no this Colin Farrell is and
he's great and he's great um they're
they're I'm not going to spoil the big
reveal at the end of the movie but I
will say this it involves a wizard that
they've been telling us is bad but we
have no real way to know as bad as
Gilbert Grindelwald that just goes up
all the most out of all tomorrow because
Voldemort is so tied to Gary Potter so
at this point he would be a zygote if
the one else's ball set because Tamra
wouldn't be old nothing right pre
Baltimore préval tomorrow but I never
got a sense of why Grindelwald is so
horrible like he's just uh he's bad guy
they mentioned like newsreel footage and
like spinning newspapers like I am NOT
invested in being evil so I don't care
if anybody stops him right I don't
really did any [ __ ] put a lightning
bolt on a baby's head no that's what I
need unbelievable
you need to threaten children to get on
my radar of de Ville this guy's out
[ __ ] in the world
less you fight a baby you're not a real
wizard you got to come correct son
that is not correct enough Voldemort now
there's a bastard fought a baby scarred
him for life and then hit a piece of him
in it which sounds dirtier than a minute
he was a Horcrux eat that even subs
dirty oh JK Rowling so see I cannot um
ZUP I cannot wholeheartedly recommend it
I mean it take a bra thumbs up it's it's
it's sugar bra trending downwards like
it's a handsome production like it looks
great and twenties magic world the low
score poster hi handsome production
that's abruption says mama nada this is
why now Hitler starving Berlin who is uh
what uh who directed it a David Yates
who directed like the last for Harry
Potter movies so they got the guy they
got the guy like it by all lights it
feels as if and it has some of the
texture of Potter he just doesn't have
any of the sort of heart coming
slaughter coming Friday the 18th fluid
that's a Thanksgiving in advance of
Thanksgiving here it is um speaking of
advance of Thanksgiving I've also seen
the Moana the latest how is it the
Disney cartoys on the folks that made
Zootopia from the vows made and but more
importantly directed by John Musker and
Ron Clements who did Aladdin oh and a
little mermaid really yes I got me
excited these two old Han animated 2d
animators coming to Putin for the first
time bringing some of that sweet sweet
magic
lin-manuel Miranda let's go take our
two-dimensional drawings and blow them
up into three-dimensional strums look
the side of this process works well we
can we did Smee get me balloons those
guys who do anything yeah with songs
written by lin-manuel Miranda the
Pulitzer Prize winning Tony
award-winning
Grammy Award and I know this did they
keep this quiet was this ice it's a to
know D was in the merry he's in the Mary
Poppins sequel he's in the Mary Poppins
to with Emily Blunt and he's apparently
working on the live-action remember
Alison is so good it's such a brilliant
piece of art that it seems like Disney
just backed up the money truck and was
like take all the money but write a song
here's the thing he got the job before
Hamilton blew up why yes he auditioned
for the job is there an interview from
yeah with like four or five other
songwriters and like I just got it like
I was still writing Hamilton when I got
that job I didn't know that yeah I
thought it was a reward of sort not at
all MARY POPPINS movies a reward that
totally like all of the awesome that has
come his way since then which is legion
and deserved because he seems to have
become a celebrity overnight
yeah and handles it about as well as
I've seen anybody handle yeah that level
of celebrity I agree you know that like
oh yeah I'm going to the White House and
Obama's blowing up my text and
apparently when the world goes bad
people want to hear from me like
BuzzFeed is collecting his inspirational
tweets into galleries because elders
those are just like the page collector
like oh another tweet click another one
click another one click click because
it's the best we're talking about but
it's still they don't do that for
everybody know any whiff like Oprah and
Lynn Miranda apparently Wow but to
inspiring people to inspire people of
uninsured people but no Milan is really
really it's lovely it's about it's about
this girl she's the daughter of the
chief she will be the chief of this
village on this island and they are sort
of they they live on this island
everything there's coconut everywhere
it's not Maui Motor Nui is the name of
this Isle but the island is dying
because apparently there's some some
like Polynesian myth about this this
mother island that gave birth to all the
other islands but she's got this magic
stone that was stolen by Maui was a
demigod who should have went against the
natural order and stole this magic stone
and with a stone Gong the world has
started to die hmm and it hadn't touched
their little island until now and so she
has to venture forth fine Maui kanra
temp to put the stone back on the island
and then that will set the world a right
now a good guy or a bad guy
Maui is a misunderstood guy in this
movie he thinks he's a good guy the
world sees him as a bad guy but his plan
was I'm going to steal the stone to help
create more islands I want humans to
have everything they want I gave you
fire I gave you this I pull islands out
of the sea and I wanted to give you the
power but I didn't know that by doing
this I've set the balance of the world
off kilter
Maui demigod played by Dwayne Johnson
the rock the rock formerly the road
Foreman
the rock now the sexiest man alive yeah
that's right and it's it's a simple
story it's a simple story in the same
way that like Mad Max fury road is a
simple story it's we're going here and
then we're going back there
but the the market when you're doing a
simple story then the world gets to be
so rich you get to build things on the
fringes you get to make sure that
everything sort of lived in and feels
right like their [ __ ] in Mad Max that
you could not do if it was a complex
plot like if I've got to pay attention
to reversals and twists and duplicity
and and betrayals and all that [ __ ]
then I can't I can't watch this dude
blaze good to you I can't see the do for
it I can't see those do swing it back
and forth I can't right I can't just in
take that world and digest it if I've
also got to be paying so close attention
to the plot right Milan is that way also
there's so much just like lovely around
and the songs are great not as like
obsequious and ever-present as let it go
was right but they're so lovely I mean
it's it's it's a song and it's funny I
saw that movie
on election night like I went to I went
to a screening and they asked me when
they set up the screening is like it's
gonna be election that you sure you want
to do that I'm like you know why not
celebrate yeah well I was like no matter
what happens I feel like being away from
the world for a couple hours would not
be the worst thing ever and it was a
lovely that a respite you know cuz what
amount you're like life is good it's
like wonderful hey what's the election
results so far ahead of XI mark go back
into the movie yeah it's like split
again um but so yes no matter how you
feel about whatever the election results
were we can all admit that this was one
of the more contentious sort of
fractured campaigns oh yeah ever so it
was nice to be able to just remove for a
little bit and that's a perfect remove
and even after it no one can also say
regardless of what your political
beliefs are that we are in a harmonious
part you know of a sort of American
society we're healing now I mean that a
you gotta there's got to be a break and
then you get to heal after the break you
don't heal unless is a break and
hopefully he'll stronger than you were
before but before the healing you can go
and like disappear into a movie theater
for a little while
Momo Moana so do the Moana anyway I was
on Supergirl set during the election day
mmm I'd sent to my boat like in advance
but mailed in but the it was nice to be
like because that election has just been
every moment of the news cycle for the
last what feels like two years hmm so it
was nice on the final day to be like I
am I want to worry about what's going on
with this Kryptonian okay yeah like
let's let's make-believe for a while
what else you see I've seen a rival
which is currently infants abs and now I
want to see if you're gonna and go looks
amazing it's really good is really it
looks like smart smart sci-fi it reminds
me of the science fiction that like I
read growing up like science fiction was
always like literature of ideas there's
always about allegories and because
especially in science fiction you can
only write about yourself the stories
are always about humanity it's always
about you know if it's Star Trek it's
the the white alien with the black side
and the black alien with the white side
and they can't ever get on the same page
because one of them thinks it like it's
we're talking about race but it's aliens
like you did like pure blue did in
planet it's totally like you get to use
allegory and wield it as a weapon to
convey a message and this is a movie
that on the surface feels like every
other alien invasion move you ever seen
alien ships come here and we don't know
what they're saying and we think
everything's going to go to [ __ ] how are
we going to stop them the roland
emmerich version of this is Independence
Day and there's everything blows up and
welcome to Earth and all that [ __ ] this
is the version where nobody throws a
punch there's never a laser beam fired
there is never any real rancor until the
very end and the solutions for it are
understanding hmm you know it's like
Close Encounters that way hmm and I
remember watching Spielberg do Inside
the Actors Studio and Gil James fluffy
with his giant stack of blue cards yeah
said so Steven your your father was a
computer engineer right so ya know
that's what he did for a long time and
your mother what does your mother do
she taught music in schools it's like so
I find it interesting that the first
movie you write the key to communicating
with aliens to saving the planet is to
talk to them through the computer using
music like that synthesis of those
- like you get - you get to do that kind
of things in science fiction that it's
hard to do with anything else right and
this movie has that kind of like that
deep think that emotional core and that
like we're solving this problem with our
minds as opposed to with our bodies or
with our laser guns that Will Smith's
help punch it in my [ __ ] now yes
welcome over with no slow she's no
cameras no explosions I'm out all right
this one's pleasure yeah we got one you
guys blowed up real good but yeah
there's a version it's movie like it
makes a left turn every time you think
it would take a right really and that
right is the conventional Hollywood
blockbuster that's that you just sold
the ticket to me right there yeah did
well they did very indeed strange dr.
strange it was yet number cleaning the
[ __ ] up at the box office
congratulations horrible at once again
and scott derrickson yeah but this is it
number two I think I did better than I
thought it would
yeah it made over 20 yeah I made 24
million they were projecting seventeen
or six good sounds laughs I went in some
money yeah absolutely
ah that sounds good I'm going with ya do
that doom owada
I mean if you're gonna do fantastic be
some I didn't say not to but just for me
it didn't it didn't give me what I
wanted out of a movie like a little more
I want to feel we're not saying Dumble
don't but you're saying like Dumble with
caution don't wash it Hartford on deli
time I'll double for ya what anything
else you see oh I've seen a lot I've
seen allied the the new my Oh Marion
Cotillard directed by Robert Zemeckis
the Zemeckis movie Zemeckis joined and
it's just world war two spy thing where
it's not a trailer for it he plays a
Canadian spy which you only figure out
about halfway through
connects in it does he hit is a because
he like I'm undercover
yeah yo I kept on imagining that he was
the the American from inglourious
basterds stuck in there I Riva derchi
Enrico Colantoni and it's it's a
beautiful like Robert Zemeckis does not
make movies that don't look amazing you
know and also there that are like very
sort of technically proficient and a
bunch of special effects that are meant
to be invisible one of our greatest
American filmmakers that's not know I
will say this I've also never seen
somebody who was so amazing at having a
good time at the movies yeah forget how
to have a good time at the movies this
is the guy I made Who Framed Roger
Rabbit for Scott read Back to the Future
movie back to the future and what's that
[ __ ] movie what lies beneath what
lies below man seeing the stone I want
to hold your head and I use cause
Romancing the Stone don't mind it mother
oh my god it's so [ __ ] good like
that's what he did he take my little
mule Pepe I mean he was a glove he was a
spielberg protege gonna remake that yeah
I don't hey kid I mean do you think they
will
I don't think so that was kind of like
hey Raiders of the Lost Ark was big
let's do this yeah but like and also
romance in the middle of it like what if
it was like Raiders meets like Joan
Collins
God it was so good it's so much fun it
really is it's a little even as
watchable - yeah I mean a great hello
Johanna um yeah yeah but like he made
amazing like our show's over the end
with the boat yeah I'm like for that
with a with the alligator shoes yes he
puts his dog what a charmer us that's so
good but yes Mike has had a fantastic
run and then he went into like this
digital Valley and made the the Train
movie the creepy train movie with Tom
Hanks Polar Express that animation you
fell in love with was not yeah one of
many favors and then he did Beowulf
which I mean I still can't like you so
Neil Gaiman Road yeah but it's like this
animation is like weird and I feel like
you forgot how human emotions work
because you'd been spending so much time
conjuring them out of nowhere
for these movies that when he came out
of that like I kind of like flight but
it's a bit of mo movie like flat just
been blood gel recently yeah I can tell
you like it yeah like it's it's remote
but I get power sooo because of Denzel
at the end of the day in Leicester hands
that's a drinking movie yes totally but
in in the hands of Bob Zemeckis like not
only is there that centerpiece sequence
of the flight right him turning the
plane upside down but it's pretty
gripping like Denzel between Zemeckis
and Denzel they elevate them yes you're
like what for sure it is and then had
Melissa Leo she's you have him
the walk the the that's the title of
global of it like you know crossing the
Twin Towers see I mean the wall gets
beautiful is technically astounding I
mean it's it's and that's what Zemeckis
does like few people do but he's at this
emotional remove and you never connect
with those characters and allied is much
the same way like it's it's love then
look at but it's and it's a thriller
that doesn't thrill although you see all
the bones of what a thriller should do
right it's just it's it's a weird it's a
weird little movie they're gunplay
yeah there's done its World War two it's
a world war two spy jammies Nazis snot
sees Nazis galore yeah but Brad Pitt
fight Nazis that sounds like inglorious
bastards I'm done in though I want my
damn scalps won't Moscow but yeah that
is that is my movie roundup of the
things that I've seen this is what you
get when you got a guy with legitimacy
in this business man who works for the
papers the papers get the papers the
papers someday they'll catch on yeah to
this con he gets he gets to see some
[ __ ] early man you heard it here first
for first looks at [ __ ] movies yes
mighty mark barnard and indeed that it's
all good that's a two thumbs up to one
kind of man shake a bra and then a
little yeah and then yeah - yay - man
there you go that is [ __ ] life man at
least it's not - yay and - thanks oh
yeah this was a which of your time and
money
that's right so essentially none of it
was a waste your time none of the two of
them was an exceptional use of it
absolutely to them I would see twice
more times really now and forever I
praise hey there it is
folks [ __ ] that's all the news there
is man tune in next week and we'll have
more for you really right back from the
vans we get back on the regular I'm here
for like I'll travel for another month
so we get to dive into the news and suck
the [ __ ] of pop culture that's what it
says man we suck the [ __ ] of pop culture
my mom doesn't like that on the business
so much this is full mark must you hang
out with that filthy boy dear goodness
he's money some people like a bomb he's
I mean his wife loves him yeah there's a
people I mean there it is folks for fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith and I'm
the mark barnard come back next episode
we'll do this again man good times at
North sitting around talking about the
[ __ ] we love come on pop culture is
better than [ __ ] no culture and let's
be honest is better than real culture
most of the time keep popping kids there
it is man for fat man about me I'm Kevin
Smith mark Bernardo tune in next time
same bat time same bat Channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you